du hast mich jetzt schon die hörst du
mich über auto ich weiß zwar nicht beruf
abendessen gehst aber ich gehe nicht
abends zu einer eisdiele leute bevor
dieses wieder losgeht muss ich noch
einiges loswerden und zwar erst mal ein
paar spielregeln ich weiß nicht ob er
das video gesehen habe wo siri so meinen
tages einkauf gemacht hat ist halt die
idee gekommen und ich habe es auch in
den kommentaren gelesen dass ich doch
einfach mal sehen wie bestimmt einen tag
mein leben machen soll ich finde die
idee eigentlich echt mega cool
leider muss man sagen dass sie halt
nicht also schon gut programmiert ist
aber noch nicht so gut programmiert ist
dass man halt alles mögliche fragen kann
und sie auf alles möglich in der antwort
findet wenn ich hier zum beispiel frage
hey siri was soll ich heute mittag essen
so also eine klare antwort auf meine
frage kriegt man halt nie das heißt die
spielregeln für das heutige video sind
ich bin mir auch nicht sicher ob ich so
geladen werden wenn es nicht klappt
klappt halt nicht immer wenn sie in eine
bestimmte richtung eine antwort gibt
dann muss ich selber daraus
interpretieren was ich jetzt als
nächstes machen sollen weil sie halt
wirklich nie genau mit ja oder nein
antwortet das ist es immer so ein mir
egal das gleiche gilt auch wenn ich sie
frage was soll ich essen dann nehmen wir
einfach immer das oberste ereignis also
immer wenn sie nach irgendwelchen sachen
so von mir ganz viel vorschlägt nehmen
wir einfach immer das erste genau also
das sind die spielregeln jetzt geht's
los mit dem video ich wünsche euch ganz
viel spaß und die leute die sich jetzt
wieder fragen gehe mal schlafen du hast
augenringe leute ich weiß dass weg auf
der kamera also ich hab echt immer ein
bisschen augenringe weiß ich nicht warum
das ist einfach so mir geht's super top
dieses all i can ist einfach so gut die
zeigt euch jeden einzelnen pickel und
jede einzelne falte und so weiter und
wenn ich dann noch so in euren stil
filter drauflegen ist es immer so ein
bisschen blut an meinen augen als
erklärung und jetzt geht's los
hallo wie gehts ausgezeichnet danke der
nachfrage
willst du mich fragen wie es mir geht
und ich hallo sie ist der jetzt auf und
du stehst dann hast du jetzt schon so
leute ich finde gerade aufgestanden hat
mir die haare gemacht und als erstes
würde ich jetzt ganz gerne mal einkaufen
gewinnt siri wo soll ich einkaufen als
erstes einfach möbel und mehr wo soll
ich meine lebensmittel einkaufen
okay wir nehmen einfach das oberste 150
meter entfernt und jetzt wird einkaufen
siri nenne mir eine frucht wir haben
jetzt als erstes orange das kann sich
schon für heute
siri nenne mir eine schokoladensorte sie
mal als ich gefragt
sie hat als erstes kinderschokolade
vorgeschlagen siri nenne mir eine nudel
art das übersteigt möglicherweise eine
möglicherweise das us-treasury nennen
wir ein getränk das wirklich sicher bist
du komplett dumm das ist doch nicht so
schwer siri wenn ihr mir fanta cola oder
streit darf ich mal eine cola kaufen
ich gebe mir jetzt einfach mit cola
kaufen
das war jetzt einfach ja das ist das was
ich meine ich hab sie gefragt darf ich
mir ne cola kaufen und sie hat es nicht
verneint deswegen machen wir das jetzt
könnt ihr euch eigentlich genau so
vorstellen wenn ihr jetzt eure mutter
fragt mama da habe ich mir eine cola
kaufen und sie sagt in welches geschäft
möchte denn dann hat sie halt nicht
gesagt sein dass sie keine cola kaufen
und dann dürft ihr euch natürlich eine
cola kaufen
so sichert erlaubt nudeln orange und
cola korrekte gedanke man haben sich
verliebt
hey hallo siri bewusst wo eigentlich
also bist du auch ein erdling hast du
irgendwie ein kurzzeitgedächtnis du bist
richtung windows da hast du vollkommen
recht so in serie
habt ihr fragen darf ich jetzt mit der
fußball gucken da haben wir die nächste
interpretationsmöglichkeit sie hat mir
jetzt die spiele gezeigt dass heißt
verneint ist es ja nicht so leute am wir
haben jetzt abends und suchen jetzt
einen restaurant in der umgebung hallo
maria siri nenne mir ein restaurant in
der umgebung dummes ding restaurant in
der umgebung
eiscafé sowie haben hier ganz oben ein
eiscafé hast du eigentlich überhaupt
nichts mit dem restaurant zu tun aber
dessen jetzt ein eis und danach wurde
ich mal was anderes wie du bist absolut
dumm ich gehe deswegen die ein eis essen
aber eigentlich will ich was ganz
anderes essen
ich habe wieder eine eiscreme ich glaube
ich bin so leute ich habe mir jetzt das
eis gekauft 22 das ding ist nur focus
wenn er das ding das paar oder irgendwo
drauf ich bin nicht sicher ob ich das
eigentlich habe ich gar nicht gemeint du
mit dummen
ich weiß zwar nicht wie du abends essen
geht es dabei ich gehe nicht abends zu
einer eisdiele
wir haben jetzt hier 4,9 kilometer sieht
man dass die fette kuh da war ich noch
nie da will ich hin also danach gehen
wir hätten gut
die frage ist jetzt direkt nach hause
gehen oder kurz noch spazieren
also ich bin für nach hause ich bin für
nach hause ist das okay wenn wir wieder
nach hause gehen
zweiter weltkrieg die höchste die die
hörst du mich über auto und so war hätte
ich gerne den weg zu die fette kuh in
köln die suche nach der wegbeschreibung
die fette tun
gesteht jahre war ich danke ist wohl
cool
wir fahren jetzt dahin erst etwas
leckeres ich bin sogar ein ich zufrieden
mit dem ergebnis weil ich habe sehr
gerne essen und dann schauen wir mal
weiter
vielleicht so ich suche jetzt hier fette
kuh da war ich noch nie vor so leute
fertig gegessen
ich muss wirklich sagen eigentlich bin
ich in köln immer nur bei einem burger
lagen aber der war auch richtig lecker
da muss ich eigentlich mal sagen sie
rief hast du super gemacht
[Musik]
siri befindest du eigentlich mein auto
die reverse cooler marie oder ich
kontaktinformationen für marie aber ich
rede gerne über mich selbst mach mir den
weg nach hause arme laconium kannst
deine karte mit einem kontakt entfernen
so jetzt ist dann wirklich aus wie man
halt mal so dass man wohl die aufsuchen
eine folge situation und zwar haben wir
jetzt abend ich weiß nicht ich bin
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen helfen sich
die kann man noch ein bisschen heller
der höheren stufe und wollte einmal von
dir wissen wie es dann aussieht
bezüglich irgendwie erfüllen oder so
wenn man abends dann gern noch mal
schauen kann
du kannst ja mal eine auszeit so und
zwar sie jetzt noch mal einen neuen
versuch serie und zwei hätte ich gerne
einen super schönen romantischen film
für den abend um ihn ja gut ausklingen
zu lassen noch das eine oder andere glas
glühwein schlürfen zu können um dann
danach schön schlafen zu können
was sagst du dazu nennen wir einen film
cool wie björn melin drama 2016 also das
wird mir als erstes angezeigt in den
hauptrollen es ist der sommer lenz 83 in
italien und elisabeth ein frühreifer
17-jähriger verbringt seine tage
lampe zu meiner familie damit klassische
musik zu spielen
zu lesen
freundin maria zu führen
und das ist nicht so 16 eur 99 kostet
der sirenen mir einen film auf amazon
prime schauen kann
der letzte krieger action 2018 ab 16
jahren borders guckt also das ist hier
gerade das of crime enthalten das
einzige was ich habe also ich muss jetzt
an dieser stelle leider sagen natürlich
serie erst gesagt ich soll call me war
ja mal gucken aber dafür gebe ich jetzt
garantiert nicht 17 euro aus deswegen
gucken wir jetzt der letzte krieger das
war die zweite empfehlung kannst du den
film jetzt muss jetzt gucken im 13
jahrhundert kontrollieren die mongolen
und ihre führer vatikan ein großteil der
damals bekannten welt auf ihrem weg nach
westen richtung europa dringen sie in
das letzte unabhängige russische also
das ist genau mein geschmack und co
leute ich schaue jetzt erst mal den film
und dann melde ich mich und sage euch
wie er mir gefällt und siri designs
natürlich auch so leute es ist schon der
nächste tag ich bin gestern eingepennt
dieser film der war so komisch und zwar
ging es da irgendwie um so krieger aber
das war so ein bisschen an trash
angelehnt also ich hab es überhaupt
nicht verstanden und einer halben stunde
kommt nicht im ganz noch nicht mehr
folgen und irgendwann bin ich
eingeschlafen auf jeden fall spielen ist
vielleicht deutschland wir haben schon
irgendwie nachmittags ich wollte noch
mal kurz wie du bist absolut dumm der
film war scheiße die den film den wir
gestern abend empfohlen hass der war
absolute vollkatastrophe so was kann die
aber nicht mehr guten film verschlagen
aus ok google sehr witzig ich lache mich
zwar nicht schlafen
siri wie hoch gewinnt deutschland gleich
leute ich dreh am rad bedeutet dass auf
jeden fall in fetten noch nach oben da
ich weiß nicht ob ich gestern oder wie
viel ich gefilmt haben muss ich gleich
mal schauen sie wie soll ich jetzt auch
noch mit youtube ja